so tens of thousands of protests in
prague against czech government eu and
nato this is a u.s news story from
yesterday
an estimated 70 000 people protested in
prague against the czech government on
saturday calling on the ruling
coalition to do more to control the
soaring energy prices and voicing
oppositions of the eu and nato
organizers of the demonstration from a
number of far-right and fringe political
groups
including the communist party said the
central european nation should be
neutral
military and ensure direct con contracts
with gas suppliers including russia
police estimates to put the numbers of
protesters at around 70 000 by
mid-afternoon
the aim of our uh
demonstration
is to demand change mainly in solving
the issue of energy prices especially
electricity and gas which will destroy
our economy this autumn event
co-organizer gerald havel told
idnes.cz news website the protest
was held at a day after the government
survived a no-confidence vote amid
opposition claims of inaction against
inflation and energy by the way this is
going on in uk this is going on in
europe uk prices are up 89 percent
norway saying to charge a tesla today's
a hundred bucks just to charge a tesla
this is a real crisis that's going on in
europe yeah what are your thoughts on
this uh
well
how do you open this up this is
extraordinary i mean people are
genuinely worried about the planet about
climate change
on the other hand ill-devised policies
unrealistic
expectations of others naivety if you
like
placing our dependence on manufacturing
or energy sourcing or whatever from
regimes that are autocratic uh us
germany uh they put all their eggs in
the they are in the basket of trusting
the russians to supply them with energy
um
you then you've got people like the sri
lankans who said we'll be purer than
pure and we'll phase out
or artificial fertilizers because it's a
major emitter and now they're people are
starving and writing in the streets
we've got a massive problem this is a
real issue this is this is really good
time if badly designed policy will lead
to massive political unrest everywhere
and if we're not careful it's going to
do something else
we will weaken our own economies
massively whilst we make the autocratic
regimes stronger yeah so then this goes
back to
did we do the right thing to get in the
way nato constantly trying to get
ukraine to
be a part of it to go against what putin
was asking for because here's
here's what we just said this is a new
york post story europe's energy fears
mount as russia keeps its gas pipeline
closed that's right the planned
reopening of russia's main gas pipeline
to germany was halted saturday after
state energy from
gaspron uh said it found an oil leak in
a turbine of north stream one deepening
fears of a winter energy crisis
throughout europe the announcement
fueled
accusations that russia is seeking to
weaponize its
sway over the world energy market which
would you be surprised i wouldn't be
this was in this was predictable
and it was predicted former secretary
mike pompeo wrote on saturday i told you
so tweet i warned germany not to rely on
russian energy energy security is
national security which is why we must
reign our energy independence president
zielinski of ukraine also took to social
media to condemn the development when a
state turns energy poverty or hunger
into a weapon it harms everyone in the
world yeah well i mean these are these
are the ripple effects of some decisions
that you make you're going to piss off
putin and you can play this game two
huge issues here for western societies
the first is naivety
we've got to stop leaders especially
should not be naive
whether it's the chinese saying no we
won't militarize the south china seas
and we say oh well you're nice people
you won't well what did they do
they did it you know in the middle east
don't cross this red line we cross the
red line what happens
naivety
is inexcusable in leadership
that's the first point the second point
is the massive dishonesty that pretends
you can have your cake and you eat it
too we don't have the technologies yet
to move to renewables and net zero we
have neither a political nor a
technological pathway to net zero by
2050. now i happen to believe i i'm not
a climate change denier i believe we
need to take these things seriously but
i think we'll utterly if we abandon our
humanity and firm in terms of feeding
people
if we hand over control of the global
architecture to the forces of darkness
the rules-based international system
that the americans put in place i mean
the west put in place as the victors
after 1945 but the americans drove and
have upheld ever since
if we're going to break those what we'll
actually do by not being honest with
ourselves about the real policy options
before us the real choices that have to
be made
we'll do the very thing i've touched on
here the the very wealthy the people
pushing all this stuff leaning on
governments save gaia i don't know do
you have that expression here it's an
old roman thing you know the the
environment god earth is god
mother earth now we all want a safeguard
i don't know too many people who want to
damage gaia but there are other things
that go with it and you have to be
honest with people and if you're going
to have all the tech billionaires and
all those people who've become so
staggeringly wealthy telling governments
that you've absolutely got to force
everybody to buy a tesla and you've got
to you know
make them do all of these things in the
name of climate change without
explaining the cost
you're setting yourself up for the very
destruction of a trust-based political
system like democracy so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]